In this video, we're going to walk
through everything you need to know to
set Ninja Trader up properly and have it
effectively work for you and not be
frustrating. We're going to go through
what data to select, how to set up
charts exactly how you want, every
little trick and tool that you need to
know. I've used Ninja Trader for over 5
years now, and as well, we're going to
go through how to set an ATM strategy
up. This is a massive thing when it
comes to trading in Ninja Trader and you
will really want to know how to set that
up properly so you can effectively enter
and exit trades. If you want to skip to
something specific, make sure to just go
through the chapters at the bottom of
the video. Now, first off, if you've
never used Ninja Trader before, it's an
extremely powerful trading platform.
I'll leave a link for you to get started
with it below. Now, first off, when you
are selecting what kind of trading data
to get from Ninja Trader, every trading
platform, you generally have to acquire
specific data. Now, on the Ninja Trader
website, what you're going to want to do
is you're going to want to go to the top
right and go to settings. And then from
there, you'll go to plans. And what this
will do is you're probably not going to
see I currently have something already
going here, but you'll want to see this
where you can either update subscription
or you'll just see select some kind of
market data subscription. Now, the two
main options they give you is you can
either do, you know, level one data or
level two data. Now, level two data is
really expensive if you don't actually
need that kind of information. And what
you can do is this level one data for
$12 a month will give you every market
out there. You can click here to view
products or what you can do is you can
go down to customize and you can say and
go through each one of these and say
which ones you want. They have some
crazy, you know, I don't even know what
kind of futures data this is at $140 a
month. But what you can do is if you
don't want to pay that $12 a month and
you say, "Hey, I just want to trade, you
know, the ES futures and the NASDAQ
futures, you don't even need to get that
$12 a month, you can just select that
specifically by going with just the
CME." And if you're ever unsure of what
these each have, you can just click view
products and it will tell you exactly
what's in here. You can see the NASDAQ
futures are in here and also the ES
futures and a lot of other markets. And
so that's a really easy way to get cheap
data without having to pay a ton per
month, which is pretty standard across
every trading platform. Now, when you
first open up the Ninja Trader desktop
platform, what you're going to do is
you're going to just get a window like
this. There's going to be no charts or
anything, and you're going to have to
connect to your data stream first. And
so, what you have to do is you have to
go up here to connections. And then you
can see I have a couple ones here that
are set up already. But what you're
going to have to do is click configure
down here. And then there's going to be
a ton of different available feeds here.
And so that's what you can do is with
Ninja Trader Trading Platform is you can
connect to a ton of different platforms
if you don't actually specifically want
to use Ninja Trader as your brokerage.
And so when you start using Ninja
Trader, they're going to send you an
email with information of how to connect
and which one of these to use to connect
your data. And then you're going to have
to just have a username and a password.
And then what you can do is just click
connect, automatically connect on
startup because then every time you open
up, you won't have to go up here and
say, "Okay, I want to connect to the
system." And then you can see these
green buttons or down here. This will
light up as green when you're connected
and you should see data and your charts
once you have them up will start to
update. If it's yellow or red or gray,
you're having issues connecting. Now,
you won't necessarily have a ton of
different accounts here, but what you
can do is you can click add simulated
account and you can just set them up and
make more if you want. Now, one thing on
Ninja Trader is the trading platform
doesn't necessarily reflect your
commissions and so you need to add what
you have. most likely you have the free
version and so and then you can also
just create initial capital and and set
up essentially a simulated account and
then you know you'll click okay and it
will make an account for you. Now to get
into charts and how to set up a chart
what you're going to do is at the top
here you're going to go to new and
you'll go down here to chart and what
it's going to do is it's going to bring
up this data series. This is essentially
you saying okay what do I want to trade?
You're going to go to instrument. And
now this up here is basically a quick
look back at what you previously have
been doing. But most likely you won't
have that if you're starting a fresh
system. And so for me, you know, okay, I
want to look at futures. I'm going to go
to futures here. And I'm going to just
pull up the NASDAQ futures. And then
from there, it'll populate this area on
the right. And what you can do is you
can say, okay, what type of chart do you
want to do it on? minute, second day.
You know, you can change it to all the
different options you want. You can go
based on volume, range. I like to use a
minute chart. You can set it up to be a
one minute chart. And then you can load
data based on different things. And so I
usually like to just load, you know, 15
days worth of data for a one minute
chart. It just gives you enough time to
zoom back if you want. And then from
there, this stuff is pretty standard.
You can always go back. I'll tell you
I'll show you how to go back and find
this. Just click okay. I'm just going to
double click to make it full screen. And
the first thing to get those settings
back, you'll see now a ton of buttons
here at the top. This button right here,
it's called data series. It'll bring all
those settings back up. So, if you ever
want to go in here and change things,
you can now see you can start to, you
know, there's lines on the chart and
stuff. You can start to change those.
You can also come in here and actually
change the colors of your candlestick
bars if you, you know, feel so inclined
to do that. I actually normally use
white and blue for my candlesticks. I
don't actually like trading red and
green candlesticks just cuz they uh you
know kind of trigger uh anxiety or
emotions a lot easier. Now, some super
quick basic things is you can leftclick
to you know drag and move the chart
around, but generally it's kind of
locked. And what you can do then is hold
control. I'm holding the left control
button and I can move it around a lot
more freely. Now you can see I can move
it all the way here. I can go off the
screen. Now, if you're off the screen
and you want to snap the chart back,
there's just this little F button up
here at the top right corner, and it'll
snap you back. And then this arrow here
will also pop up if your chart isn't
matched to the right side. Now, if you
rightclick on the chart and go down to
properties, this brings up other
settings that you can do. Now, first
off, a big key one is right side margin.
I usually have this at something like
200. And it just that the right side
margin is just this area right here.
Basically, it essentially just is, you
know, how much extra space do you want
there? You know, I kind of like having
it a little bit extra space. It helps me
visualize things a bit more. Um, and
then kind of some big things is you can
turn on or off horizontal grid lines or
you can just make them thicker, you
know, and most of these settings are
pretty self-explanatory, but that's how
to do a lot of that stuff. Now, if you
ever want to kind of save a preset, you
see down here, you can click preset and
you click save. And so, it'll save that
kind of as your default chart setup.
Now, you can always just click and drag
on the X or Y-axis of the chart, too.
That's another easy quick way to move
the chart around. Now, if you want to
add indicators to your chart, you can
click this indicator button up here. And
you can see there's a ton of default
indicators you can add or there are
custom indicators. These are custom
indicators I've built for the platform.
It just comes in a nice little folder. I
can add this one. And you can just
click, you know, it'll always have all
the settings right here. And you can
always click pretty much for anything,
any drawing tools, any indicators. This
template down here, you can always click
and then click save as default. And then
that'll always be the default that's
there. or you can save it as another
option. And you can just click okay and
that indicator will show up. And all
that indicator is is just a little timer
right here just to show you a countdown
timer of where the bar is going to
close. And so that I find that super
helpful to have especially trading on a
one or five minute chart. For something
a little bigger, it's not as necessary.
Now another important setting is I can
click on the right side axis here and go
to properties. Now this brings up
properties that are important to use as
well. So, one thing I like to do is I
like to have fixed horizontal grid lines
versus automatic. And so, what this
does, you can see it didn't do anything
because I technically have, if I go back
to properties here, I technically have
horizontal grid lines off. And so, what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
reshow these. I kind of like actually
having grid lines on most of the time.
It makes things a little easier. But, so
what you can do here is you can have it
as fixed grid lines versus automatic.
automatic kind of just make it kind of
look nice. Now, the reason why I like
fixed is because you can do it based on
ticks, points or pips. Now, what I like
to do is I like to have it based on
points. And this is because anytime you
open a chart is, you know, and just look
at the candlesticks without an an easy
reference, it's kind of hard to
understand the volatility of the market.
Now, if I put in here that I want a
horizontal grid line every 10 points.
Now, this is on the NASDAQ. It's going
to show me, you know, grid lines that
kind of make sense. You know, this is
kind of today's chart. And then if I go
back, you know, here, you can see the
grid lines are a lot bigger, showing you
visually, very easily, that the
candlesticks are much smaller and
there's less volatility versus if I zoom
back forwards, you can see they're very
tight. And so, there's a ton of
volatility going on today. And that is
super easy and really important for
trading consistently every day I think
to be in tune with how the market is
moving. Now the next big thing for
charts of course is drawing tools. Now
if you right click on a chart you can
bring up most of the settings that are
up here. Pretty much you can see there's
data series alerts. Another thing here
is if you want alerts you can set up
alerts for Ninja Trader. You can say hey
I want to add an alert and the condition
is if the NASDAQ you can actually do
this based on lines as well. So you can
say if I draw a line here and I actually
you can rightclick the line and I can
set an alert based on that line and it
will pretty much automatically set it up
for you and I can say okay I want to
alert if the price crosses below that
line. You can, you know, go in here and
change it exactly how you want. But
that's something super helpful if you
are, you know, not actively trading.
You're, you know, I I want to see this
and, you know, I want to come back to
the charts if it shows up here. And so
what this will do is it'll send an alert
to you if the price crosses this line.
Now, to go back to this, there's a
couple of other settings here. You know,
you could have crosshair. I like to put
local crosshair on. Just for me, it kind
of makes it a lot easier to visualize,
especially if I'm looking to enter in a
trade. It kind of allows me to easily
visualize where I am based on the actual
x-axis. And then another thing too here
is this is where you can easily get to
drawing tools. I find it a little easier
to just rightclick and then pull up
drawing tools here. And you can see
there's, you know, a ton of different
drawing tools. There's your classic
lines, your pretty much your standard
setup that every platform has. And so
what you're going to do is, you know,
for me, I like to use rectangles for my
support and resistance zones. And so
what your rectangle is not going to look
like this initially. And what you can do
to bring up properties like every other
drawing tool, you can rightclick or just
doubleclick it to bring up the
properties. And then it'll bring up your
properties. And you can say, you know,
for for this, you know, I've have the
opacity really low. You can change the
colors. You can say, "Okay, I want it
specifically on just this chart." Or if
I have multiple charts, I want to have
it come up on all the charts. And so,
we'll go into multiple chart setup in a
second, and I can show you that more.
But again, down here, the template is I
save this as default. And so, my default
is every time that I pull this up, it's
a, you know, an exact setup of how I
want. And so, same thing with this, the
line, any other drawing tool I
consistently use has some default
setting that I really like. Again, you
can also get those up here at the top
left. Now, let's get into making
multiple charts. Now, so for multiple
charts, first off, if you go in the
bottom left, you'll see a little plus
sign down here. This is if I want to
make another tab. And so, you can go in
here and, you know, set up, okay, I now
want to, you know, let's use the micro
ES futures. And I'll click okay because
I think you know my my kind of default
is is works for me. And it will bring up
the micro ES futures. And you can see I
I have a bunch of saved charts or or
drawing tools on my chart because they
you know it's saved in my system from me
actively trading this morning. That's
one way to easily make a chart. Or you
can rightclick on this and just say
duplicate in new tab or new window. The
nice thing about that is if once you
have all the chart settings exactly how
you want, you can just easily duplicate
another one so you don't have to do it
all over again because that's kind of
annoying. And so just to bring these two
charts side by side now you can see that
these drawing tools are, you know, the
same on all charts. But if I select one
minute on it, it'll only be on this
chart. It won't globalize it to all
NASDAQ charts. Now, one cool thing to
show you is if you go to the top right
here in each of the charts, you'll see
two little red boxes. Now, what you can
do is this is how you can link the
charts via instruments. And so, what
this does is I don't know why, but for
some reason for me to get to work, I
need to put both as red. And so, what
this will do though is if I change this
chart to the ES futures, it'll change
this chart as well. Or if I change it to
oil futures, it'll change both charts.
And as well, if you want to use
something like a superdom, you can link
this as well. So, if I go in here and I
change to a different chart, you'll see
this changes to the ES futures as well.
So, that's a super nice way if you have,
you know, some specific setup you have
and you just want to cycle through
things like that. That's a super easy
way to do that. Now, when it comes to
quickly drawing, I find it really
important to have hotkeys. And so what
you want to do is pull up your Ninja
Trader main window. And if you go to
tools, you can go to hotkeys. And what
you can do then is you can go to it'll
you can do chart, market analyzer, all
these other, you know, superdom. But for
drawing tools, what you can do is you'll
just scroll down and your main drawing
tools you'll find here. And you can
change them to different hotkeys. I just
use F, you know, 1 2 3 4 and 5 above
number 1 2 3 and four and five just cuz
I find that super easy to do and it
doesn't normally mess up a lot of other
hotkeys that there are. Now, one thing
to save your charts once you have them
set up how you want, you need to go to
workspace and then click save. Now what
you need to do is if you want to make a
new one just click new here and it will
totally start you fresh and it will have
a saved one that you can start from
scratch and go from there and just
quickly to you know open up you know
kind of your main setup. You can easily
do that by clicking you know that last
whatever you have it saved as. Now, if
you ever have any questions about
specific things on Ninja Trader, all you
have to do is click F1 and it will open
up a help window on the internet
specifically for that area that you're
looking at and it will give you a ton of
helpful tips. So, if you ever, you know,
if there's something I didn't talk about
in this video, which I'm sure there is,
you can easily find that there. Now, now
let's get into the chart trader. So, if
you go back up to chart settings and
options, just click this chart trader
button and it'll bring up this side
panel. Now, this is really important for
entering and exiting your trades on the
chart specifically. If you want to use
the superdom, you can totally use that,
but personally, I like to use entering
in on the chart. Now, if I right click
above the chart, it'll give options for
buy stop market orders or sell limit
orders. And below, it'll do the the flip
side. So I can click and put in a buy
limit order. And you can see here this
is the order quantity that it'll get put
at. So right there I have four
technically. You can change that pretty
easily and you know just put in one
contract if that's what you're kind of
looking to do. Now a couple important
settings before we get into setting up
your ATM strategy is just right click on
this and you'll bring up properties. Now
you can change a couple things in here.
You can change the colors around, you
know, kind of basic things. You can show
P&L. You can also change the length.
Now, if I put in another order here, you
can change the length that this comes
out. And that is just basically by this.
I can just double it to 50% in the
screen. I kind of like to keep it 25. It
keeps it on the side. Uh, and then you
can change the display units that. So,
if I just quickly click buy up here,
it'll fill me in order. And I can change
this to, you know, display percentage.
the technically the percentage isn't
your count, it's the movement in that
market. And then, you know, you can
change it to ticks, you can change it to
points. Points I think is probably the
most standard. Or you can just have
none. This is actually what I commonly
use on my charts is just display none
because at the end of the day, I don't
want to, you know, think about the
money. I just want to try and be making
the logical decision based on, you know,
what the chart is doing. Now, probably
the most important setting of this is
your ATM strategy selection mode. I like
to do keep selected because what it will
do is it will select your ATM strategy
order every time you enter in a new
trade or contract. So, it'll allow you
to keep them selected and you know, you
can see here it'll it'll separate them.
If you want to instead it have it
essentially select the active one to
where they're combined. You can see here
if I do it, it'll it'll add it as eight
right here. And so it'll essentially be
it'll combine them versus breaking them
up. And you can see here it's only on
one specific one. And so that's just you
know kind of an important thing to do
with that. Other than that though, you
know it it's pretty self-explanatory
like most things. Now, let's get into
setting up your ATM strategy. Now,
you'll need to click down this drop-own
menu. Usually, you'll have none
selected, and you just need to click on
custom to bring up the parameters for
setting one up. Now, the basics of how
this works is it'll have a order
quantity. That's how many contracts or
shares, whatever you want to are
trading, it's going to default to be
putting in. And then you can select
based on the parameter type. And so that
is meaning down here when this enters in
I want to have it have a stop loss of
let's say 50 ticks. Now I can change
this to you know points. And so what
that'll do is if I just click okay based
on that and I click buy market this
stop-loss is 50 ticks away from my
entry. Now if I go back to that and edit
it again I can also add in a profit
target of 50 ticks. And if I click okay,
buy market, essentially it makes a
bracket order. And this would be
essentially a 1 one risk-to-reward
ratio. And so now to get more
complicated here, what you can do is you
can click add and you'll you can create
a second target. And so let's say I just
want my first target to be at one times
my risk and my second target to be at
two times my risk. And so what you can
do here is your quantity. Then I can,
you know, I can have it be half and
half, right? If I'm going to enter four
contracts, I want two contracts to be at
1x and two to be at 2x. And then you can
see this, it still keeps these together,
but if I right click on it, I can move
them separately. And so the only way
I've figured out to really do that is
click increase price and then we'll kind
of separate them. And then you can
easily kind of separate them and then
move them based on that. So like let's
say I want to move one to break even and
I can. And then what happens is, you
know, when this hits, I don't know if
it's, you know, to kind of speed things,
you can see there, it got hit and it
closed out the two limit orders here and
the two stop-loss orders there and I
only have two left. And then you can,
you know, continue to trade based on
those. Now, the other interesting thing
is if I let's say I am changing like I
go in here and say, okay, I'm going to
trade eight contracts. I have that same
custom parameter selected. You can see
here this is broken up in two and two.
And so if I click buy market, you can
see it breaks it up in two and six. And
so how that works is essentially if we
go to if I close this back up, you can
see the first target is taking most of
them and the second target is capping
out at two. And so this is how if you
quickly change that without changing
this because in real time it's kind of
annoying to go in here and change how
you select this is you can have this to
be larger and then you know if I trade
four contracts it'll just fill the first
one but if I trade you know eight
contracts it'll fill them roughly you
know half and half and I let's say I do
10 it will you know do four and six and
so it's pretty hard to perfectly break
things up how you want. Now, one way to
do this though is that I I would say I
generally do it is instead is, you know,
you just have one target. If I just
click here to remove that other one and
I click buy and let's say I have 10
contracts. And so what I do to kind of
deal with the issues of, you know, it
not always breaking things up properly,
what I'll sometimes do is I will say,
okay, well, I'm going to put in a limit
order of, you know, six contracts. Now
I'm going to change my order quantity
and just manually put in for six
contracts. And so if I quickly drag this
down to try and let it get filled,
you'll see it filled there. And boom,
this order changed to having four and
this order changed to having four. Once
that order was hit and closed out, it
essentially updated everything else. So
you don't have to worry about, you know,
this essentially still being at 10 and
this still being at 10 and, you know,
you potentially accidentally getting
more contracts than you mean than you
want to get. Now, of course, what you
want to do with this is once you have it
set up how you want, you want to click
save as template. And then I suggest
saving it as something that makes sense.
You know, how many ticks your stop loss
is or how many, you know, what the
riskreward ratio is. Now, one thing you
can do too is if you have your profit
target as zero, it will only put in a
stop-loss. That's actually what I do
most of the time. And then I will
manually say, okay, rightclick, you
know, I have four contracts. I want to
take half off at, you know, let's say I
I would be targeting this high up there
because I think that's likely where the
market's going to reverse. Now, if it
breaks out, you know, this will change
to two and I can slowly trail things up,
right? That's a little more fluid way to
play things out that I like to do. But
again, as you can see in here, if you
click on more, I didn't really talk
about this. There's a lot of different
things you can do to have things, you
know, trail up basically automatically.
You don't have to do it manually. Now, I
don't really like to do an automatic
trailing stop, but there's ways in here
to essentially set that up to do that.
You can basically make it so it'll, you
know, have a stop strategy right here.
If I click custom here, you can see
it'll bring up an auto break even. It'll
bring up a trailing stop. It gets, it
can get a lot more complicated than what
I've just shown you. But for me
personally, I kind of like to keep it
simple because I'm, you know, managing
based on what I see on the chart. Now,
one thing that I think is really
important when it comes to trading on
Ninja Trader and just trading in general
is knowing how much money you're risking
per trade. Now in futures and you know
when we discuss how the candlesticks can
widely range I don't think it's smart to
say oh I'm going to consistently be
entering in four contracts because you
know four contracts today in this market
could be a huge amount of risk that
you're not normally used to. And so what
I do and what I've actually built for
Ninja Trader is a riskreward tool. It's
called ET riskreward. You won't find
this natively on your platform. you'll
just see the normal riskreward tool. But
what I've done is I've kind of adjusted
it to where essentially it'll allow me
to have like for me right now I have a
target risk of around $700 per trade.
And so you can see well if I want to
enter in here and put my stop loss let's
say above this little swing if I want to
try and get short well I need to trade
seven contracts and so I need to adjust
this to seven contracts. What this does
is it actually automatically adjusts
that cuz you can see if I want to then
have, you know, a larger stop-loss, like
if I entered up here and I want to put
my stop loss all the way above this
swing high, well guess $700 of risk for
that big of a swing, it's actually only
four contracts to essentially target
around $700. And you can see what's nice
about this is it automatically updates
the order of quantity to, you know,
based on this adjustment. So you can
easily see okay where am I you know how
much am I risking how much do I need a
trade to hit that risk and then you can
see it also has just basic targets in
here one times two times three times
your risk how much money that is at this
current risk and you can easily adjust
this if you know if I say hey I want to
trade $100 you know this market's kind
of wide for $100 but you can see here
okay I could still enter in $100 here
but it needs to be one contract and so
this is extremely important when it
comes to trading to pay attention to
because otherwise you're just going to
blow your account because one day, you
know, the size is way smaller and you
can see, you know, maybe $100 is if I
zoomed in cuz the contracts are smaller.
$100 is four contracts, but today $100
is one contract. And so that's really
important to pay attention to. It's
something I highly recommend checking
out if you are serious about using Ninja
Trader. I'll leave a link to, you know,
how you can get this in the description
below. And as well the other thing that
I built for Ninja Trader, I have a lot
of tools I built for Ninja Trader, you
can check them out in a link to below,
but one other really important one I
think that really improves trading on
Ninja Trader is, you know, you have to
rightclick to click buy or sell, right?
And what this tool does is it allows me
to just hold a hotkey and click buy or
sell. And so that's super valuable when
the market's moving quickly or if you
just kind of want ease of access. And
you can see it it adjusts. These tools
together are really powerful because I
can quickly say, okay, I want to enter
in here. I want my stop loss here. And
boom, four contracts. Or if you know
because the way this changes, I can
easily say, oh, now it's six contracts.
And so those are super helpful. Now,
these are custom Ninja Trader
indicators. And so they're a little
tricky to install. And so how you
install any custom Ninja Trader
indicator is you go to this main Ninja
Trader tab window again, go to tools and
go to import and then you'll go to Ninja
Trader Script add-on. And so what it'll
do is it'll just bring up a folder
directory. And what you need to do is
you need to then go and find, you know,
wherever you put it in your computer and
where you put the third party add-ons
you're looking to install. Now the
biggest issue I see with all of them is
if you have it located in your one
drive. You cannot have Ninja Trader
files of thirdparty indicators located
in your one drive. They need to be stay
as a zip folder and then placed on your
computer in a local folder. If you have
it in a one drive, the arrow will often
pop up like this. And all you'll see is
just a bunch of directory. But what
you're looking for is for it to say one
drive. If you see one drive in that,
that means it's in a one drive folder
and you need to move it into a local
file. Now, just to show you the other
really cool third party custom indicator
I've built is just a news navigator I
call it is essentially just you have a
big list here that shows you every news
event possible across all markets. You
can change it to, you know, just be in
the US. And you can see here on the on
the chart as well, it also will give you
vertical lines. So when you're trading,
you can see that, okay, there's a bunch
of news coming out, you know, kind of in
the morning and then there's a couple
other news events in the afternoon and
you can see, okay, which news events are
important and what to stay away and be
aware of because when you're trading,
you know, news is really important to
pay attention to. You don't want to jump
in a trade, have a news event come out
and just, you know, wipe out your trade
all of a sudden. So those are really
helpful to really, I think, unleash the
power of the platform. I've used it
again, you know, for 5 years and over
the time I built these because I felt
that they just improved the platform and
things that they didn't have in the
system natively. And so I'll leave a
link for all those Ninja Trader
indicators in the link in the
description below. And if you want a
more in-depth explanation on futures
trading because that's what I mainly do
on Ninja Trader, check out this video
right here. I go through every nuts and
bolts explaining the ins and outs of
futures, how they work, and how I trade
them consistently every day.